Hi everybody. My name is Mano Marks,
I work at Google,
and I'm being a little blinded by
these projectors. But, my job is,
I'm a developer programs engineer,
and I work with KML. So what this
means is I help people who
have questions with KML,
want to incorporate KML
into their applications.
This is Pamela Fox, she is my
counterpart on Google Maps.
And we are going to
present to you today the…
the quick and dirty KML creation.
Pamela, your laptop is not
behaving. Okay, that's good.
Thank you. Alright, enough
of those disruptions.
So, before I get started, I
want to introduce a couple
of other important people who
are in the room right now.
There is Josie Warnakie, who
wrote the KML documentation,
she is our tech-writer extraordinaire.
There is Michael Ashbridge,
who is a, he's one of two…
I don't know what you do!
He's one of the engineers who
works on KML, and is one of key
people involved both in the
development of KML and in the KML
standards process, which I
can talk to anybody about,
or he could, later.
And there's Michael Wiesmalik whose
the product manager for KML.
And John Gardner, who
writes the KML user guide,
I'm sorry, the Google
Earth user guide,
and also has blogs
about Google Earth.
So did I miss any important
Googlers in the room?
Any unimportant Googlers? Okay.
So let me tell you a little bit
about what we're doing here.
I think it was about
two months ago,
Pamela came up with the idea
of having a geodeveloper,
a Google geodeveloper series,
which would be, where
we explore some of the,
the, hopefully some of
the more practical
and also lesser known aspects
of some of the API's
that Google uses.
And we thought we would
start out with one of
the practical basic ones, which is
just how to get started with KML,
which is one of these questions
that comes up quite frequently.
So, so that's what
we're doing today.
Quick and dirty KML
creation using,
using tools that Google has
created for doing that.
So what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
go through using Google Earth,
show you the basics
of KML creation,
and Pamela is gonna go through and
talk about using Google MyMaps
and the spreadsheet mapper, and talk a
little bit about the Maps API, as well.
So, at any time, if you
have any questions,
please feel free to ask them.
Remember, you are being videotaped,
so anything you say may
be going up on YouTube.
And if, so, seriously though,
you know, feel free to stop me
if I'm talking too fast
or you just wanna,
you're really interested
in any particular issue
or you wanna see something explored
a little bit more in depth.
And I'm getting signaled. Yes?
Since you're going to be speaking
about spreadsheet mapper,
I should probably introduce myself.
I'm Christian Adams. I work with Google.opg
and I helped to build that product.
Ah, excellent. Sweet, okay,
great. So that being said,
any questions before
I get started. Yes?
Why did you guys build Google Earth?
Okay. I told him to ask that
question out, out in the hall,
so I didn't have to answer
it question more than once.
Why did we build Google Earth?
So Google Earth was originally built
by a company called Key Hole,
which we acquired, which KML stands
for Key Hole Market Language,
Key Hole is from that company.
Why we originally built Google Earth,
or why we acquired
it is because
we are strongly committed
to their being more
content on the web.
We believe that organizing
all the worlds information
means organizing all
the geographical
and geographically
tagged information,
essentially, geographically
based information.
So everybody says to me,
“Well how do you make
money off of this?”
We make money off of
search and ads on search.
And yes, there are ads on
search results,
I actually look sometimes. I
won't tell you to click on them.
And that includes search
for geographic content.
So we create these
applications
because we believe strongly
that there should be
more content that is accessible
and presentable on the web,
and that's how we make
our money off of it.
And, and so all these free
applications that you see,
that's why they're free,
cause we want you to have the
ability to organize your,
and present your information and
have other people search them,
and we believe that's a,
a good business model.
Any other questions
before I get started?
Okay, I am going to
jump right into it.
So, first of all tell
me, show of hands,
who has, who has
used KML before?
Okay, great, who has
created KML before?
Good, good, so this should
not be too difficult.
And I'm assume everybody who
raised their hands has also used
Google Earth before? Yes? Okay, cool.
Alright, so this will
be then probably
the quickest part of
the presentation.
So, basically, just
a quick review
for the folks
listening at home,
we, KML is Key Hole
markup language,
it is an XML markup
language that is used to
describe geographic
presentation data.
So it's job is to show you
things in Google Earth,
or in a earth browser.
It is used in many
Google properties,
particularly Google
Earth and Google Maps.
It is also being
released as a standard,
so we are giving it to the
Open Geospatial Consortium,
the OGC, and that
means other companies
are now starting to adopt it,
including, for instance,
Microsoft and Yahoo! both have
incorporated KML
in some of their products, either
in consuming or producing it,
and there are many other
applications out there that use it.
So let me go over the basics of
creating KML using Google Earth.
Now I really like this
part of the presentation,
because often people, including
people at Google who have used KML
for quite a long time don't realize
that this is a capability that you can
have in Google, in Google Earth.
Like me. Like Pamela.
So, the most basic thing you can
do in a geobrowser, in anything,
is to say, “This is here.”
So you use a placemark.
So in Google Earth, you click
on, “Add a Placemark,”
you give it a title, I'm gonna
call this, “test placemark”
because I'm not feeling particularly,
particularly eloquent, today.
I'm gonna give it a description.
“This is Pamela's house.”
That's not true! It
is not actually true.
We do not give out the addresses
on YouTube of Google employees.
You can select the
color of the label.
I'm gonna give it some strange green
color; The color of the icon.
I'm gonna give that blue, which
because the icon is yellow,
comes back strangely. You can
even select the icon itself.
And I will give it a ‘P'
icon for “Pamela.”
I'm gonna pick on her just
because, you know, she's there.
You can change the viewpoint,
this is where the,
where, when you double click
on a placemark, it jumps to.
And I'm gonna click on center
in view, to pull it there,
snapshot the current
view as the lookout.
I'm gonna do that. You can select
the altitude and the altitude mode.
So I'm going to draw that up,
and I'm going to extend it to
the ground, which you see,
puts that nice cool line down
to the end, and click okay.
Now you have a placemark, and it's
sitting in you're "My Places"
in Google Earth. Now, the trick is,
the thing that most
people don't realize,
and I'm gonna open up now
what I should have had open
since the beginning
which is Notepad.
So you can use any text editor,
you can do copy, paste, and…
It's good for demos. … and
there you have your KML file.
So this is a, this is a
really new trick,
most, many people don't know
you can actually do that.
And what people also don't realize is
that you can do it the other way.
So, I can now, for instance,
I'm gonna change,
I'll go through a little bit more of the
details of what's actually in here,
but I'm gonna go ahead and
change the name of the file,
so, “Pamela's Summer House” and I
am going to change the P to an F,
cause I happen to know
that's a different,
different, icon, that's
for Pamela Fox,
I'm gonna do that
here, as well.
Do you wanna give them my
number while you're at it?
Sure. You wanna speak it out loud
for people who can't read online.
And, I think I'm doing this
in all the right places,
but the font is so large,
it's hard to tell.
And then I'm gonna change
this to, “A Cool Placemark.”
And then, I'm going to copy. So
here's one of the limitations.
This placemark is still here.
I copied it out, but it's still there.
Just something you're know about.
I'm gonna talk in this about how,
you know both the strengths
of Google Earth as a,
as an editor and the weaknesses.
So, Pamela, are you watching the time
at all, if I go over too long just…
Okay. Just tell me. So I'm gonna
delete the old one out, press paste,
control V on windows boxes, and
look, I have “A Cool Placemark”,
and it's got the right icon
and everything.
So, I think that's a pretty
cool aspect of Google Earth.
Now you can do this with
a variety of things.
You can create, for instance,
you can add a polygon,
which you can give a style, a color
to the line and a color to the area.
You can, again, change the viewpoint,
not gonna bother with that right now,
and change the altitude,
and even, if you want,
extend it to the ground.
And you can change things like
the width of the line around it.
So, I don't know if you can
see that on the video,
but the line is
thickening considerably.
And you can change
the opacity,
I'm gonna change the opacity
of the polygon inside.
You can even give it a
random color if you want.
Click OK, do the copy and paste, and
you'll see, again, we have a polygon.
An untitled polygon.
And again, I could do the same
way I could copy and paste it
back into Google Earth.
Similarly, you can do a line string,
and you can add an image overlay.
Let me show you, because the
interface is a little different
for image overlay,
I'm gonna show that as
one way to do this.
So you add the image
overlay, you browse to…
that is the right…okay….and
there you go.
You have an image
overlaid on the earth.
Well, but that might not be the exact
location that you want it, right?
So you can click on this,
the middle cross, and
change the location.
I'm going to try and get it to roughly
actually match the United States.
As you'll see, that image is actually
of points in the United States.
You can change the sides
and the size there.
And you can use this here,
let me get a little closer to that.
See there's this little
diamond right here?
You can use that to
change the rotation.
Again, you can change the
view, altitude, so, say you
wanted to raise that
up a little bit.
I find that less interesting.
You can change the
refresh times.
So, with images, particularly images
that are sitting on a webserver,
you can have them
refresh periodically.
So say you have an image
that changes once a day,
or once every few minutes.
So a lot of people use this for
instance for a, for web cams.
So you want to have a web cam,
you have a web cam that for some
reason's actually pointing
at the ground, it's particularly...
useful….and that would be
somebody joining us.
So, we have a video
conference system,
and somebody's just joining it.
You can't actually see them
because we've turned that off,
but that's what that noise was.
And you can change the
bounding box there.
Okay, so I'm sorry, what I
was saying is the,
if you have a web cam that is
an image that refreshes every,
you know, ten seconds, every minute,
you can set the refresh time
so that it would refresh that.
You can also change the view-based
refresh, which is,
a topic for another session.
If you let them join, but have it
be in the background, thanks.
Okay, click OK, and again,
just so you can see this,
I'm going to delete
that, paste here,
this is actually a much
simpler KML for overlays.
So, what you see here,
here's the image, the scale,
and the bounding box for it.
Okay, any questions so far? Yes.
How are you getting to the notepad,
what you're showing the
code, the source-code?
Just to reiterate that, I
copy, and here I,
I was just using keyboard
shortcuts to paste.
So that's control V…. Can you show
them this in like Crimson Edit?
Just to show you can
use any program?
Yeah, you can use any text editor.
Crimson edit….ah, okay.
Is this your favorite text editor.
Yeah, it has in-text highlighting.
Oh, sweet. So does NotePad++,
that's what I tend to use.
So there you go. Okay.
So, that, those are the basics of
doing the basic geometries for,
for Google Earth. Yes?
Can you use a GIFF or a PING
instead of a transparent color?
Yes, you can use, there's a,
there's a long list of image
formats that we support…
So you can make the white
transparent and then make
it look like there's a
bunch of dots on...?
Yes.
Oh, that's cool.
And, if you're using
Google Earth Pro,
you can use something
like a GeoTIFF file,
as well, which would
have, imbedded in it,
the geo, the coordinates.
But if you want it to be
compatible with Google Maps,
you should use GIFF, PING, or JPEG
and also don't use the rotation,
style, the rotation property, because,
we find it difficult to rotate
images in the browser,
so we don't do it.
Any other questions? Okay. Yes?
Working in XML is so much more
difficult than working on the map.
When would I want to move it to
XML and play with it there,
because it seems to me like,
when you're on the map,
it's so much easier to actually...
That's a really good question.
Let me, let me show one other
thing that you can add,
and then I'm gonna actually
get to some of the weaknesses
of this approach.
So one other thing that you can add
is, actually, a few other things,
you can create folders which will
allow you to organize your content,
so I create a folder,
untitled folder,
and then I can drag Pamela's
summer house into it.
C'mon….and untitled
image overlay…
there we go….you can
also add a line string,
you can do a 3D model,
you can add a photo,
which allows you to do
the photo-overlays,
which I'll show you a little bit of
in a minute what those look like,
and then, you can also
do a network link.
So let me do a photo-adding
and a photo-overlay.
I'm gonna use the same
image so you can see
the quite major differences here.
Again, you have view,
you can add,
have a lot of information here that
you can edit about the photo.
You click OK, and you'll
see the photo overlay.
Let's actually get a
little closer to that.
Did you put in “Mano's Mom”?!
That is so funny! Okay.
The photo overlay is
something that hangs out,
basically, as a billboard.
This is a not…this is kind of
useful for lo- res imagery,
it's really useful for very
high resolution imagery,
and we're actually gonna
have presentation devoted
to photo-overlays later
in the series,
so I won't get into that too much,
but play around with
that feature.
So this, basically, enters
a different view,
you can sort of navigate
within this photo.
And there's a layer,
the gigapan layer in,
default layer in Google Earth
that you can play around with
a little bit more.
Okay. I exit photo.
Okay, so why would somebody
not want to use this?
This is a really good, good tool
for creating a basic geometry.
It's a good tool for creating
a template of geometries.
But say I created a
bunch of placemarks,
and then copied and pasted
them into a text-editor.
What you would see is that for
each placemark that I created,
it creates all the styles,
and if I create one document
that's got all the
placemarks in it,
it's gonna have a whole bunch
of style, styles in there.
So what that, you know,
say you create a folder,
you copy and paste that out,
you're gonna have a
pretty complicated
and much larger file size, basically.
And it's gonna be
not that pretty.
Basically, anybody who looks
at the XML will know,
“Oh, I know. They just created
that in Google Earth.”
I don't think that's
necessarily a bad thing,
but it doesn't show off
your excellent expertise.
There's other features that you can't
use that you have to do in XML.
For instance,
time-based animation.
You can't do that using Google
Earth or any of the other tools.
There's no way to create that by, you
know, within these gooey editors.
So you'd have to add the timestamps
and timespans yourself.
Also, we have a new balloon
templating through extended data,
which works in Google
Earth, but not in maps.
That's a really powerful
tool, and again,
not something you can create
using, using Google Earth.
So that's sort of the downside.
I think, what I find it most useful
for is creating a set of styles,
“Oh, I really like the color
to look just like this,
I like this sort of….”
Also creating the
exact placement.
If I want to mark something, I go
in, I put the placemark down,
in Google Earth,
I copy it out and then I
can grab the coordinates,
and I know what I'm,
I'm working with.
But if I wanna create a
large number of files,
or if I want to do
something dynamic,
I'm working directly with the
XML or writing a script that
does it for me.
Okay. Any other questions?
I think that's right around the
time we allocated to that, right?
Okay. Cool. Alright.
Pamela, it is now up to you.
And now the awkward
pinning on of the mic.
It's okay, I wore a collar. Hello.
It's good? Yeah?
Alright, sweet. So that was
Google Earth.
Which is obviously 3D,
now we're gonna move on to
the 2D equivalent,
so we'll start off,
how many people have
used Google Maps?
Yea! So, I actually, so my brother's
birthday was on Valentine's Day,
and I called him up and he's like,
“Pammy, what are you doing?
What are you up to?”
I was like, “Well, I work
for Google now.”
He was like, “Yeah,
what do you do?”
And I was like, “Have you
heard of Google Maps?”
“Nope, no.”
I was like, “Have you used Mapquest.”
“Yeah.”
Okay. So, so you guys are all
ahead of my brother. Yes.
Try not to hate your family too much.
So, so now we're gonna go for those
of you who have your laptops open,
let's go to maps at Google.com…..
Okay, and also,
another question, how many people
have used the second tab in
MyMaps, in Google Maps?
Sweet. So how, somebody tell
me what that tab is for.
It's freaking awesome!
That's what it's for.
Right, so, you could
have made that up.
No, I mean, it's, like, I mapped
out like where Google was
and made a little thing for where
I wanted to go and look around
and stuff, I mean, you
can't mess with that.
Did the same thing when I went
to Europe and went to Paris
and I “Like, a hotel's here and a
hotel's there, and it's this far away
from the Eiffel Tower”, and
it was, it was awesome.
So, exactly, so one of the
things you can do in
that tab is create new maps, right?
Yeah. Okay, cool. And the
other thing you can do
actually is you can load in
maplettes, and maplettes are
actually like Google gadgets,
but they work inside Google
Maps, and they operate on the
main map, so it's a good way of
like, so let's say you're
planning your trip to Paris,
right? So at the same time, you
could actually load in a
maplette to show like Panorama
photos around Paris or the
hotels around Paris, right?
So it's a good way of overlaying a
bunch of data at the same time.
So there's two aspects to it:
the creating maps and the, you
know, loading in maplettes or
loading in other people's maps,
right? So this is what we call
MyMaps, so you talk about doing
one for Paris, I'm planning my
spring break to Costa Rica,
right now, so I've got, I've
got various things on here.
I think this place has good lobster.
So I'm willing to go to Costa
Rica for good lobster.
So that's a map I've
already created,
but let's start by
creating a new map.
So a lot of this is gonna
seem kinda similar to
what we just saw in Google Earth,
and this is just our Google Maps
equivalent, but there are a few
features that are different,
particularly since this is a web app
as opposed to like a desktop app.
So when we do “create new map”,
we have a couple of options
here that weren't here
when it launched, so I don't
know if everyone's seen it,
but we have the ability to collaborate
and the ability to import, right?
So the first thing we're gonna
use is the ability to import.
So this let's us pick a
KML file from on the web
or from on our, our computer,
and have it loaded in and
be a map that we can edit.
So, Mano, did you save
out your KML file?
Oh, I didn't.
Well, we're just gonna
have to do that.
So “Save As,”….yes…. so
I'm gonna right click on the
folder he created
and save this, I'll just do
a KML file for fun,
so “Mano's Cool KML.”
We'll save that to the drive,
so then I'm gonna click on “Import,”
….let me discover it….
Mano, Mano, Mano,
where'd you go?
I think it's in My Documents.
Yeah, you're right.
Alright, so we'll go there instead.
My Documents is kind of long.
I need to learn how
to use folders.
When is Windows
gonna have tagging?
God! So we're gonna
say, upload from file.
Sweet, so this is apparently
where my home is.
You put my summer
home in Wyoming!?
Or is that Colorado? Okay,
that's, you know, it's okay.
Next time, let's think right
around here. Okay, good.
Alright, so cool. So now
I've loaded his map,
and you can see how
some of the 3D features
you obviously don't
see here, right?
Cause we don't have altitude.
So this polygon is flat
on the map.
The marker is flat on the map.
But it still translates pretty well.
So we'll give a title,
“Pamela's way cooler
map than Mano's.”
I'm not sure that's good English.
Description, “This is cooler.”
Alright, so now we can
start editing it,
so we have a couple
tools up here, right?
And we have the ability to create
markers, make lines, and draw polys.
The other thing we
have an ability to do,
which is our other option here,
is to collaborate, okay?
So this is really cool because
then, it's like, you know,
I'm planning my spring break
to Costa Rica,
I'm obviously not going by myself,
because that would be really sad,
so I've shared the map
with my friends,
so that they can add their
ideas to it as well,
cause, in case not everybody likes
lobster, we may not get to go.
So, I'm gonna collaborate
and invite Mano,
so Mano is, he's got his
laptop set up over there.
Hi. Okay. And I'll let him
invite others, just in case.
And if you want to, you can actually
make a global collaboration.
So if you want the entire
world to edit your map,
you can say, “Allow
anyone to edit this map.”
So you're giving a whole lot of
control to the whole world,
and let me warn you that there's a
lot of crazy people in the world.
But you're welcome to do it,
and you'll probably come up with
some pretty interesting results.
So, send the invitation,
hopefully Mano will get it soon,
but we'll start playing with
the tools here.
So add a placemark.
It's gonna look very similar.
This time we're gonna give
Mano a summer home.
So we're gonna go ahead, South Dakota?
I was actually born in South Dakota.
Okay, you know what? Alright.
Sas…Sass-Kaa-Choo-An.
Saskatchewan. Saskatchewan.
Hope no Saskatchewanies
are watching this.
So this is gonna be Mano's summer house.
“It's really boring here.
No people. Don't come.”
I betcha they don't even
have WiFi there.
We can do a couple things there,
it'll actually let us put in HTML,
so we do rich text, and
then edit the HTML.
I wonder if it let's us
add a blink tag.
That'd be kinda cool.
Blink is my favorite
HTML tag ever.
I try and put it in every mashup.
So let's say “Okay,” oh, and
we can customize the icon,
so click on the icon, we see
many of the similar options
that we saw on Google Earth.
And so we'll do a volcano,
just in case there's
a volcano there.
So let's press “Okay.” And,
and when I click on it.
Oh, I really want to see
what it looks like.
Okay, we'll, once we're
not in edit mode,
we'll see if that blink
tag actually worked.
So that was creating a placemark,
and then we've got, now I really, really,
really like the line
refinement tools in MyMaps.
If you guys have ever used
any programs that like
let you draw lines and edit lines,
it's kind of tricky, right?
You know, Adobe Illustrator
has one way of doing it.
Everything has it's own
way of doing it.
I really like what
they've done in MyMaps,
and it's not just cause I
work for Google.
So the first thing I can
do is just kinda,
you know, draw this
line around here.
So this is, we're
gonna outline the area
that has no people in it,
so that Mano knows how
lonely he's gonna be.
So then we'll end the line,
but I kind a want to be a
little more detailed about it,
so, “Mano's Ring of Loneliness.”
Now, I you know, this
is incorrect, cause,
there are people on the lake,
so what we can do is just drag
in the middle of the line,
and it'll automatically
create a midpoint for us.
So this is really cool.
Everytime we drag like,
you mouse over a segment,
it'll actually show you
the possible midpoint markers.
So then, I can be like,
“Oh, okay cool.
So, I actually do want to
split the line there."
So it makes it really easy to refine
and really kind of addictive,
cause sometimes I start off I'm like,
“Okay, I'm just gonna make some
really simple borders of places,”
like I did a borders of
the U.S. states map…..
and it looks like Mano's
adding stuff to my map now.
We'll see what kind of
vandalism that results in.
So I was doing like a borders
of the U.S. states map, right?
And I and want to do it really
simple, cause I wanted
to not have that many vertices,
cause I wanted to load it
onto a map later and not,
you know, hang down the browser,
but I just, I kept on refining
it, cause it was so much fun,
and I just had to like
stop myself, and be like,
“No! No more refining.”
But it's really fun, just
trust, just start doing it,
you'll just, you're just gonna
drag midpoints forever.
So that was, that was a
line, and we can also,
I guess we should have done a,
a natural polygon here
so we can fill it.
So we'll just make this the
actual circle of loneliness.
Circle…okay.
Alright, so now we
have polylines, polys,
let's see what Mano's
done over here.
So, apparently, I now have a
winter home near Hudson Bay.
It's okay. I like living on the Bay,
I assume there's a lot of
lobster there, right?
Is it too cold for lobster?
Probably.
Aw, man. Alright, we'll
you know what.
Oh, oh, oh, guess what!
Guess what!
I get to drag this.
Oh! Oh snap!
Look whose home is
now in Panama.
Alright. This is awesome.
So that is collaborative
mapping, which is pretty cool,
and this has been used, they
used it during like the fires
in San Diego to quickly
document like everything
that was going on there,
I think they recently
had snowstorms in China,
and they also used
the MyMaps there
to be able to keep
track of, you know,
all the catastrophes
that are happening.
So MyMaps has been
very successful
due to many natural
disasters in the world.
And we'd like to
thank mother nature
for giving us the, the extra PR.
So here we have, we've
got the collaborate,
we've got the import, and
we've created all the tools.
You'll notice that we don't
have quite all the stuff
that they have in Google Earth,
so we don't have image
overlay here yet,
we don't have photo overlay,
cause that's not even
supported in Google Maps,
we don't have folders here, and,
is there anything
else we're missing?
We're missing general 3D
information, as well.
You don't have the ability
to create network links.
Right, right, so this is actually
more basic than Google Earth,
but it does have the advantage
of being collaborative.
Can you import one that
has network links?
Yes.
And then, and it will still,
will it still keep on updating?
Yes. That's cool!
That is cool.
And you can use both, you
can also use view-based
refresh in Maps, as well.
Yes. So here we've created a map,
and we can actually, we should be
able to view this in Google Earth.
Here we go, edit…
so when you actually go to edit,
it'll give you a view in Google Earth,
and this is actually just a, a KML
containing a network link to this.
So let's click on this and just verify
that it also works back in Earth.
Yeah, yeah.
It's trying to load the image
overlay that's on my hard-drive.
Alright, cool.
So now we have a, now we have
our stuff back in Earth.
So, that's pretty nifty.
Alright, so now we've got one
more tool that we want to show,
and this is the spreadsheets mapper
that got blogged about recently.
And this is using
Google Spreadsheets
in order to create KML.
This is something that Christian
mentioned that he worked on,
and possibly the person
who kept trying to VC in,
hopefully that's the guy
who created it, as well.
There, hi Sean!
Hi how's it going?
Good. Alright, so we're going
to….listen to my echo.
Sean can you lose your mike?
Yes, I can.
Alright, cool.
There's a little lag there.
Yeah, he's, he's clearly
VCing in from very far away.
So if you just search
for spreadsheets mapper,
you'll find a, you'll find this
tutorial that the Google Earth
Outreach team put together.
And this is just taking
advantage of a lot of features
of spreadsheets in order to make
it really easy to create KML.
So we talked about like Google
Earth is kind of, you know,
you're just manually
creating these placemarks.
Google Maps is the same thing.
Spreadsheets, that's a, you know, a
little bit more level of control
because think about,
you can write things
to make it easier to import
stuff into spreadsheets,
so I would actually think
of this as maybe a step up
from the other two options
in terms of sophistication.
So the first thing we have to do is
open up the starter spreadsheet,
which is a template that
they've put together.
Alright, cool. So we've
opened up the spreadsheet,
and the first worksheet in
here they've nicely made
into pretty instructions.
And, we just have to fill
out a few things here.
So, we'll just say,
“Google Geodevelopers”
for our organization name,
website URL, we'll plug the
documentation for KML.
Name, I'm actually going to import
some Seattle restaurants that I like,
so we'll call this “Seattle Restaurants”.
Description, “Yummy places to eat and drink.”
And, it says, compatible with
Maps and old versions of Earth,
I would recommend that.
So now we have to, in order to
actually get this to work,
we're going to have to
publish the spreadsheet
because your spreadsheet has to
be viewable on the web for,
for anyone to see it.
So, by default, you know,
it's private so that nobody
looks at your data.
So you just go to the publish
tab and say, “Publish Now.”
And now we just have to copy
and paste this link into here.
So, we can actually start off,
as soon as we've done that,
we can actually just
view the sample data
and see what it looks like
with all the sample stuff
they've put in here,
and we'll view, we'll
view it in Google Maps.
And I'll show you the, the sample
data that's gonna be used in here.
So our second tab,
this is what we're going to
be putting our data into,
this is a placemark data tab.
And you can see all the
sample data here.
Placemark names, folder names,
latitude longitude, that's key,
as well as a bunch of
additional information that we
put into the info window.
So here, this is the sample.
And the samples useful because
you can see they've already done
some preset templates that they
think look good and I agree.
So you can click on them and
say, “Okay, that looks cool,
that looks cool.”
And you can actually see
samples they've done where
they've actually
filled in the data.
Our resolution here
is really giant.
So you can see,
they're kinda big.
So in our case,
I don't actually have a photo
or too much information,
so I'm gonna stick with
one of the more simpler….
more simpler?
One of the simpler templates,
and that's gonna be
template number six,
since that one doesn't have a
picture, it's pretty basic, okay?
So when we want to do that,
we decide what template
we want, okay?
So we go back here, and there's
a little column here, it's red,
we can just type in that we
want template number six,
and that would've,
actually what we'll do,
we'll update all these column
headers to be what you need
to put in here, as
those vary by template.
Alright, so now let's
open up my spreadsheet
that already has
some data in it.
So some of you might
have excel spreadsheets,
some of you might have
databases to output this.
Whatever format you
have it in,
it's pretty easy to
copy and paste,
you know, as long as it's
tabbed or in the spreadsheet.
So we'll start with our
latitude and longitude.
So this is ten, no nine
different Seattle restaurants.
So if you guys go to Seattle, you
can take my recommendations,
cause they're all really delicious.
Well paste it in there,
it'll update,
alright, so we're gonna delete
these one's at the bottom
as we don't have that
much information.
And so, I'm basically just gonna
go back and forth and paste,
I don't know if you'd
recommend and more efficient
way of doing that?
So, you deleted the
rows there which is,
it's much better for the spreadsheet
to only delete the white parts.
Oh, ok.
When you delete the entire row it's
getting rid of some of the code,
Right, right, right. Okay. But
yeah, copying and pasting
like that is fine.
Alright. We'll do it, we'll do
it the way that they like it.
I only used this
like two hours ago,
but then you can see
how easy it is to use,
cause, you know, clearly,
it's not hard to pick up.
Alright, so instead of, we'll
just go and grab the ones…
I think we have to repaste
our latitude longitude data.
And the great thing
about spreadsheets
is just like the map
that we just had open,
spreadsheets are
also collaborative,
so you can share your
spreadsheet with whoever
you want to be
able to edit it.
So this is collaboration with a
little bit more sophistication,
because think about it,
in spreadsheets, you can
also do formulas,
you can do concatenation,
stuff like that.
Alright, so let's go put
some titles in here.
We'll make it the placemark
names for the titles.
I don't want to
have any folders,
since mine is just
kind of simple,
so I'm actually just gonna
clear out all the folders
since that's optional.
And then I'm gonna go,
and this is in my little
HTML that I want to have
in the window.
And I'm just gonna put it as the
paragraph header over here.
Alright. And then, since I don't
have any more information,
I'm actually just going to clear
out most of this stuff here.
Now, what you really should do
is probably edit the templates,
and you can do that, there are
actually, there in the other tabs,
so you pick the one probably
template that you like the most,
edit it to have, the, you know,
the column headers that
you're gonna be using,
and then use that
template instead.
However, since I'm lazy,
I'm just gonna use there's
and do it kind ghetto style.
And let's just do the title over there.
Alright. So if all goes well….
So one other thing for the templates…
Yeah.
You've changed, that box up
there, only changes the headers,
it doesn't set the template
you use for each placemark,
you need to change all of
the numbers in that column
to be the templates that you
want to use for each placemark.
Ah.
Ah, I see. Alright.
That one little box up above
the scroller there is only
for your guide to
change what you see,
so you can use multiple
templates in the same KML file,
up to sixty.
Good, very nice.
Learn something
new every minute.
Alright, so I'm just gonna paste
six into a bunch of these cells.
Updating, updating,
alright, cool.
The other thing to do, actually,
is when we did publish,
it defaults to only
publishing at the time
that you clicked, “Publish.”
So this trick is there's
two things here:
you can manually
republish a document,
and that might be good if
you're working on a document
where you think you
might make some mistakes
and you just want to make all
your changes, look at it,
and think, “Okay,
this is good to go” and republish.
However, if you're incredibly
confident in yourself and in all
your changes, you can click
this little button here,
which is “Automatically republishes
when changes are made.”
So I'm incredibly confident,
so I'm gonna do that.
And just to be sure, I'm gonna
republish the document right now,
but from now on, I should never
have to republish this document.
So now I'm gonna refresh
this, see how I did.
Yay!
So now, these are, this
is all my locations,
it's got the titles here, and
it's pretty basic looking,
but it's pretty cool
how fast it is to use.
And if you think about it, you
could pretty easily create
one that had thousands of
placemarks in it, as well.
So, anything else
you want to mention?
Cool. Alright, so that's three
different ways of creating KML.
Yeah?
Thousands of placemarks
is not accurate.
Up to four hundred in
each spreadsheet.
Oh okay, alright cool.
Will that change when we up
the limits for spreadsheets
one day in the ever-future?
Possibly. It's a limited
number of formulas
that we have in the
spreadsheets right now,
and there are a lot of them in
there, cause it's doing a lot of…
Yeah, right, yeah. So
there's other, there's other
things, let's see here….
You can actually, if you
want to be really hardcore,
you can browse to
the actual KML tab,
and they've done a
very good thing
and hidden all the columns
that do all the magic,
but, if you're a
hacker, like me,
you can unhide the columns,
and all the rows,
and then actually
see what it's doing.
And, this is actually
the KML output here.
So then you could, you know,
double click on these,
look at all the formulas,
see how much work they went into
this and be really impressed,
and go “Yay! Good work!”
Alright, so we've seen three
different ways of creating KML.
So one thing I want to talk
about is very easy ways to
consume KML once
you've created it,
and this would be
via the Maps API,
so once you've created
some KMLs and you,
say you just wanted to do
a basic map that shows
them all on that map,
we did add a class
to the Maps API
that makes it very easy
to display KML files.
And I'll just show you
an example of that.
That class is
called GGO XML,
and I think we've got
a tab open for that.
Here you go.
So here's a class, it's really simple,
all you have to do is send
in the URL of the KML,
it also takes in GRSS,
and then there's some other
things you can do, as well,
but just that one line of code will
give you a KML file on your map.
So, let's look at an example.
Google WiFi, don't
connect to Google WiFi,
we'll change networks.
Any questions while we're
waiting?...(inaudible chatter)....
Alright, it's fine, I can
show the documentation.
Alright, so we're just gonna go to
the documentation example here.
It's very simple.
Okay.
So, this is just
KML on the map,
this is not one that
was created in MyMaps,
but it could be, just as well.
And this, so we have GGO
XML, we passed in the URL,
and than we just add it as
an overlay to the map.
Pretty simple, we can also toggle
it on and off if we want to.
And that's not working.
So yeah, cool.
So that's a really simple
way to consume your KML
after you've created it,
and there's one other thing
I want to talk about.
So the cool thing about Google
is that search, right,
we're really good at it.
So the other thing we're tyring
to get good at is geosearch,
and this is crawling and
indexing the geoweb.
I don't know if any of you
have heard the various talks
about it, but it's
pretty cool stuff.
If you guys actually
go to Google Maps,
you can actually
find the results of,
of the, the, the stuff that
we've crawled on the web.
So let's say, and actually, you
can just specify it exactly,
so on Google Maps,
you can search
and you'll get a mix
of results, right?
We have various things
on Google Maps,
we have geocodes, where
we take an address
and we tell you
what point it's at,
then we have like, you
search for pizza
and we give you a
bunch of pizza stuff,
and that's from our
local business results,
but then, we just have all this
user index content, right?
And so this is KML that we've
found on sites all over the web
that people have
made on MyMaps
that they somehow made
available for Google to index.
So it's basically
three types of results
and now we've actually
added a search dropdown
to make this really specific,
so you can get to that by
doing “Show Search Options,”
so everything, locations,
businesses, user-created content.
So we're gonna explicity say that,
by default, you actually
get a mixed result.
And then we're gonna search
for, “Sleepless in Seattle.”
And it's good, we
get tons of results.
Now you wouldn't usually
get results for this
if you're just searching for
businesses or for geocodes,
because “Sleepless in Seattle”
was just a movie that
was about a relationship
in Seattle.
But luckily, we have tons of
people that have decided
to create KML's.
For example, for this one,
this documents the houseboat
where Tom Hank's character lived,
in case you're, really want
to go see where he lived
and relive his amazing life.
And there's actually
tons of results,
cause apparently, a lot of
people really like that movie.
I re-watched it, and it's actually
really, it's not that good.
So, I was, I was disappointed,
cause I had fond memories,
and I was wrong.
So anyway, so the cool thing is,
like, about this is that, you
can make your content available
for Google to index.
And, you…yeah.
By the way, you can do similar
searches in Google Earth.
Oh, yeah, right, of course. Google Earth.
So, let's try this. "Find Businesses" tab.
Yeah. Okay. So we
go to this tab,
which is I guess the
general search tab,
and by default, we're gonna get
the business results here,
and those are indicated by
the red icons with the,
the characters on them.
But then, we see this,
“User Created Content”
and that's are clue to
knowing that this is from KML
and GRSS that we've
indexed on the web.
So actually, that's...that's
similar stuff there.
Maybe that's the
houseboat again.
People are very into
this houseboat.
So there you go.
So the question you
might have is,
“How do I get my stuff to
be indexed by Google?”
So the key is, well if
you create a MyMap,
and you just say, you
know, make it public,
than Google will
automatically index it,
because you created it on our
server, so we know about it, right?
However, you might have
created it in Google Earth
and put it on another server,
you may have created it
in spreadsheets, right?
So in that case, what you want
to do is actually create
something called a sitemap,
and how many people
have heard of sitemaps?
Okay, cool. So sitemaps are just,
it's an XML file that you host
on your webserver
that tells Google,
“These are the files here,
please index them.” Etcetera.
So now you can tell Google,
“Hey, I've got KML files
here, please index them.”
So, luckily, we've got a nice
article that Josie wrote,
and it tells us how to put together
a, a sitemap with KML in it.
It's just under, right here,
submit your content to Google,
and it will just go through
some of the basics.
The important thing
is that we did,
we do have a way to let you specify
your author and your website,
because a lot of people
are worried like,
“Okay, so I'm letting
Google index my content,
what am I getting out of it?”
So what you're getting out of it is
that somebody sees your content
and then they see your
website, and they're like,
“Cool, I want to go
to the website
and see what else
they have,” right?
Because, most likely, your
website is, you know,
completely dedicated to
“Sleepless in Seattle”
and it's like a very immersive
experience with like Tom Hanks
like popping all over in flash,
and that's something that
I want to go to, right?
I don't want to keep looking
at these pathetic little
placemarks in Google Maps.
So that's the advantage is
that you can, you know,
for Google Maps mashups,
they can have great sites
and then drive people to those sites
via a community search results.
So there are ways to do
attribution, both in KML
through the, actually,
through the Adam, protocol,
using the author and
name and link tabs,
and then also use it for GRSS
you can use it, as well,
just using there author name.
And then, the other key,
put your KML on your
server and, or any server,
and then you just add
it to your sitemap,
just like you did
in the other URL.
So, it's pretty cool.
Imagine, you know, you
making the little file and
then seeing it show up
on Google Maps later,
I mean, you think about it, you
could make some kind of a,
try and do like a present for
your loved one, or whatever,
and do some file that contains
some obscure keyword in it,
and then they could search for it
on their birthday and see it,
something like that,
I don't know, you should definitely
hack Google Maps, though,
I highly recommend it.
So yeah. Cool. I think I've
covered everything, right?
I have a question.
Yeah.
Have you guys, I don't know
if you have that capability
of actually adding HTML
content on the marker,
as in, I know I saw you
use basic but what if you
want to do a form,
like a basic for?
Right, so the problem with
forms is that sometimes
they involve JavaScript,
and they often involve
some kind of submitting,
so, in Google Maps, you're
not gonna have too much
success with that, so….
Do you want to talk about it from
just basic KML point of view?
Okay.
So, in Google Earth, actually, if
you can just pull up the reference,
the KML reference, in Google
Earth, at this point,
we support a subset of
HTML and balloons,
which does not include
JavaScript or forms.
And if you go to the reference
and look under description,
there's a lengthy description
balloon example,
and it shows every
element that we,
that we claim to support in,
in the description balloon.
One thing you can do though,
on Windows machines,
it's currently is not
available on a Mac or Linux,
is you can imbed flash content.
And that, in Google Earth, that
can be any flash content,
it could be any flash application.
Where's the link?
So videos are the
traditional ones,
but you could do something
more interactive that way.
And, later, I can tell you
some good examples
of people who've done that.
So if you go to click
on, go to description.
And scroll down, there's a….
So, as I understand it, most
HTML will work on Maps,
but not, you can't
have JavaScript.
Right, we strip out all the JavaScript
due to the security concerns,
with people trying to like
grab the Google cookies.
And the flash that is supporting
is actually more limited,
is that right...to video?
Yeah, I believe it's actually
limited to YouTube flash.
So, yeah, the dilemma right
now is that it kind of varies
across Google Earth and
Google Maps, right now.
But forms are a
definite no, right now.
A lot of that has to do with
different security needs of
different applications.
Right. However, you can
do an IFrame, I believe,
in Maps, and in, can you do it in Earth?
No.
Okay. Right.
But you know you can make some
really pretty headers and links
and ordered lists.
Yes.
Yeah. So one thing you can do,
actually, and it
could be a good idea,
is create different versions
of your KML formats in Earth,
so one of them might take advantage
of the features in Google Earth,
like, if you have
Panoramic photos
that you want people
to browse around,
you could do one in Google Earth
that uses photo overlays,
and then, in Google Maps,
you can do an I-Frame
that opens up a
Quicktime VR viewer.
And I actually specifically
know a company that did that.
So that takes full advantage of
what both of them are capable of.
So…
And you could use a network
link that, that would
detect what kind of,
what kind of client
you were using,
so whether you were using
Maps or which version of
the other client, and then could,
the server, pass that information
to the server, the server
could use that to detect,
to serve the right kind of content. Yeah.
Could you explain to everyone
what a network link is?
Ah, okay. So I think I glossed
over this a little bit,
but a network link is basically
a short file that says,
“Go grab KML from over here.”
So, it's, it's a way of creating, you know,
you create one file,
somebody can download it,
and then they can get your most
recent content at any point.
So it has additional
capabilities, like they said,
it can do things like detect
what kind of client is
being used.
You can do view-based refresh,
which would be basically,
“What am I looking at?”
you know,
sends the bounding box
back to the server,
the server than decides to
send the appropriate content.
There's a lot of other
variables that you can imbed
within them, as well.
Did you want an example
of the really nice
use of the spreadsheet?
Mmhmm. Sure.
Yeah, now we're just gonna show
examples until you guys get bored.
Oh, and I believed a lunar
eclipse just occurred.
(irrelevant chatter
about lunar eclipse)
While I'm waiting for this to load,
a couple other things
about the spreadsheet,
since I'll plug my own work is,
and Sean's work as
well, thank you Sean.
The, there is a network link that
you can get off the spreadsheet
so that you can hand
that network link out,
the little KML file and
then it will always point
people back to your latest
updates on the spreadsheet.
Let's…what am I looking
for here? This one.
So this group, Edge of
Existence, created a really nice
KML file using our spreadsheet.
And you can see some of
their points come up here,
they added custom icons,
they made it so that the,
the label only shows up
when you mouse over it,
and then they created this
really nice HTML balloon,
let's see, there's one
that's got a picture in it.
And this was all done through
the spreadsheet mapper.
With little bit of HTML
and putting the content
in each of the rows for
several hundred placemarks.
Links to their website,
links to more information,
so lots of cool
stuff you can do.
Any more questions on that?
Oh, I'll show you what their
spreadsheet actually looks like.
If this'll load for me.
I'll also plug the Google
Earth Outreach website,
which has a number of tutorials
on various more advanced
aspects of creating KML.
Do you want to say a little bit
about Google Earth Outreach?
Sure. Google Earth Outreach
is a small group in,
within the Google Earth Geo team.
And their mission is to help
non-profits and NGOs
and public benefit organizations
to use Google Earth
and Google Maps better to
advance their, their work.
We have some tutorials,
a showcase of all sorts
of really cool layers,
and then these case studies
which walk you through
how a number of high-profile
organizations have created
really cool KMLs.
So here you see,
this is just a screenshot,
but this is exactly the
spreadsheet that they used
to create those KML files.
Any more questions?
So does a spreadsheet have to be
really complicated like that,
why can't it just
be, you know,
some XY coordinates, you know,
the data and okay put
this in the balloon?
It can. Our first version
was sorta like that,
but we wanted to give
people the ability
to use the different
balloon templates.
So you can create a
very simple template
in there if you want to,
but the purpose of this was
to give people the ability
to create fancy
balloons like this.
So it allows you to
choose, to set up six
different templates
within one file,
so different placemarks can
have different looks to them.
Now is that one
using, you know,
there's a whole bunch of
points on the screen,
but is that using
the network link
where it sends the
bounds and it only gets,
like, it only is displaying
the points that are,
that are within the bounds
of what you're looking at?
I believe this one loads
the whole thing at once.
This one's only got
probably about a hundred
or so points on it, so it's not that big.
I don't believe the spreadsheet
can do view-based refresh.
No, it doesn't.
You could, you could export
your KML from the spreadsheet
and modify it
manually to do that.
I think also what you're
asking is regenation,
where if you have
a lot of data,
you can set up a KML file to
show you sort of a zoom-ed out,
low resolution view
when you're way out,
and then as you zoom
in to a specific area,
it'll load a
different version,
which is higher resolution
of just that area,
so you don't have to
load the high resolution
of the entire file.
Exactly.
That is not built in.
We do, I believe we have
a tutorial on that.
Let me check.
So that's when you want to
start going to probably
some server side…
….Here we go.
Avoiding Overload with
Regions is a tutorial that
will tell you more about
how to use regionation.
And there's a lot more
in the documentation.
I would say, if you have more
than two hundred placemarks,
you should probably look into
a more sophisticated system
than what we've
shown here today.
I mean, if you have two
hundred placemarks that
are just a point
and maybe a title,
that shouldn't be a problem,
but if you have a, a
large amount of HTML
in each one, than
your file size
starts to balloon
pretty quickly.
Yeah there's like some,
like, when you have a KML
or a KMZ file,
there's some limit to
the size that it can be,
you know how you
go to Google Maps,
and you can just point
it to, you know,
some KMZ file, like, you
point it to that file,
and there's some file size
limit that I've never found
where it was at,
but sometimes I'll make
ones that are so big,
at it'll just say,
“That's too big.”
It should say, “That's too big,
it can only be two megs,"
instead of “That's too big.”
I think that we documented
that somewhere,
but we actually do change the
limit from time to time,
so that's maybe why we did it.
But, I mean, at that
point, we recommend
you using network links.
So that we don't,
I mean, just think about
the poor browser right,
do we really want to force a user
to go download your, you know,
gazillion megabyte file?
We're kind of forcing you
into a good practice.
Exactly.
So we're gonna have a,
you're gonna talk about the
latest refresh network links,
so if that's something, you
guys or people that have,
you know, huge
amounts of data,
and you're interested
in more specific stuff,
than you should just stay
tuned for our upcoming talks.
Yup.
This is really like, I
recommend this is like,
you know, something
you do with
your family members,
provided they know
what Google Maps is,
or, you know,
you're friends
when you're
planning your trips
and stuff like that…
It's also a good way to
get clients involved,
like if you're working
with a client to say,
“Here's how you can create
this content for me.”
And then you can take the
content ___inaudible___,
as well.
It's also a good way
to do, like, you know,
start, start figuring out what
you're templates gonna look like.
Well that, like, that
spreadsheet is really neat,
like that's really cool.
Why isn't that
one in the blog?
I didn't see anything
about that….
It was blogged about last week.
I think we haven't mentioned it
in the Google Maps API blog,
but we mentioned
it in Joe Long.
But that's a good idea,
we should do a, on
the new tutorials.
Yeah, there's so many blogs,
it's hard to keep track of.
Like, I've got them
all on Google Reader,
but they're, you know, like,
“Oh, I've got a new blog” and
then you go and add it in,
and it never ends.
So I would recommend
Google Map blog(?)
and the Google Maps API blog,
truly the Google Maps API blog
is really Maps API plus KML,
we just haven't really gotten
around to telling people that.
Right, now there's
gonna be another one,
the KML one, you're gonna
have to branch off.
It's gonna be, the KML one is,
KML is gonna stay within the
same, the Maps API blog.
It'll be more like the
Google Geo API Blog.
Right.
Well now with Google
doing everything…
Michael.
Did your blink tag work.
Oh, I don't know.
That's a good point.
I don't think we
support blink.
Well, Firefox supports blink.
But I don't think we
support it in Google Earth.
You think we strip it out?
God I hope not, oh, I'm sorry.
I don't think we do support
it maps, I don't know.
Mano's summer house.
Wait, you got rid of it anyway!
How am I supposed to test it!?
You guys can see how
fun collaboration is.
You should see what
are meeting is like.
This is what working at
Google is like actually,
this sort of back-and-forth.
Let me see, let me go
back to this…okay.
Yeah, I need to go back out of…oh, done.
Awww.
It stripped it. The HTML
wasn't there anymore.
Oh, sad. I'm going to have
to fire up a bug for that.
You know, is it true, like, is it
still true that when you print,
like, if you use
those cool icons,
they don't print out,
like, in my experience,
when, if you use,
like, a normal icon that just
has a letter on it or a dot,
that one will print,
but if you use the
little volcano one,
that one won't print.
Do people print?
So when you print...well,
yeah. yeah.
So what happens
when you print
is that Google Maps
will actually,
so are you printing
from file print,
or are you printing
from this one?
Oh, you gotta use that one, yeah.
File print is whack.
So when you do print, what
that actually does is takes
your map or whatever
you're looking at and goes
and generates, you
know, baked-in images,
so like, one flat image,
because right now,
what we're looking at here
is a lot of HTML and Dom(?)
and stuff like that,
which can be tricky for
a browser to print,
like Firefox won't print SVG,
which is like what we
do the polylines
and the polygons
with, right?
So when you click print
it goes and it creates
a flat image files of
whatever you're looking at.
Now, in the case of all
these custom icons,
you can imagine that,
that means that every time
there's a custom icon,
we have to go and add it to
this static map print server
so that it understands it.
So, you know, that's gonna
take some work to do.
So sometimes,
so eventually,
all those icons can,
like, if you make your
own custom icons,
with the maps API,
as long as you're doing
that second thing
that you're talking about, making
the static image or whatever,
like I read something
about it in the API,
but it's hard to get
stuff to print right.
Right, yeah, no,
you can't actually really
do that in the API, right?
Right now, the API
doesn't provide
any special mechanisms
for printing.
So often when you print
stuff from API sites,
you'll have, you
know, medium success,
if it's just markers,
usually it's okay,
but if you've got, you
know, polys, polygons,
depends on the
browser, right?
That's why I was saying when
in, like, in Google Maps,
so if we actually click
on print right now,
let's see what happens,
I actually don't think
much will show up.
Like, you know when you
do driving directions,
it'll actually show you like
a bunch of images in a row?
So those are all just flat
images that it's generated.
And if you zoom in, like, why,
why when you go to the
print doesn't it just
disable zooming
all together?
Cause if you go
there and then
you mess around with
that map that's there,
than it won't print
anything for sure.
Actually, I use that feature
all the time to readjust
exactly what I want to
see on the printout,
but you're right….
Yeah, than the
icons disappear,
and then I have to write
them in with a pen.
Yes.
Oh, I'm surprised,
it works decently.
So it printed the icons
but not the polygons.
So, I believe
what we're doing…
yeah, so that's
the exact problem.
Okay. So when you do
driving directions,
it does actually go and generate
images in a row, right?
And prints them out.
So driving directions
usually look really good
when you print them out.
Now KML, I guess we've
decided to just show you
the mapview and
print it out,
and hope for the best.
However, that
means, in Firefox,
that you're not
gonna get polys,
because Firefox is
SVD, and won't print.
Now, if we do
this from IE,
So this is the one time
that we like to use IE.
Yeah, I noticed
that, too, like,
when you use IE it
does it better.
Right, so printing is something
that's not resolved yet.
It's something we're
still working on.
You know, browsers
are tricky,
maybe if they all, you
know, did the same thing,
it'd be great.
Opps.
Oh, here we go.
I probably should
have done it
not from the print
screen, huh?
Well, if we did it from IE
the polys would show up.
Any other questions?
Alright, it's about seven thirty,
which is when, which
means our times about up.
Please take food with you.
Right, so, we
can plug, right?
So next week, we're having
a talk from one of the,
I would consider, one of my top,
like, Maps API developers.
And he's flying in
here from the Midwest,
so and he's gonna be talking
about creating custom map types,
and this is with
the Maps API
and creating tile layers
on top of the Maps API.
This is something
you want to do,
we're talking
about right now,
this like, this stuff
we've shown
is good for a small
amount of data,
if you've got a huge
right, if you've got the
shapes of every single county
in America or if you've got,
you know, the voting information
about every single citizen,
you're not gonna want to create
markers out of all of those,
what you're gonna want to do is
bake them into a tile layer,
which is images and load
them on the map that way.
So he's gonna be
talking about that.
He's got some, a lot of
sample code to show
and a lot of really
cool demos to show,
so that's, I'm really excited
about that one, actually,
So I encourage you
to come to that
and register if
you haven't yet.
And, this is a
related topic,
on the twenty-ninth
of February,
we're having a JavaScript
API's Hack-a-thon,
so this will include,
Maps, but also our,
our AJAX, API's, Gadgets, Gears,
JavaScript Client libraries
for our G-data applications.
So if you want more
information about that,
you can ask us afterwards.
When was that?
Friday, February twenty-ninth
is the Hack-a-thon.
Yeah, from two o'clock on.
Right, and then next, the
next event in the series
will be same time, same
place, but next week.
Alright. Thanks,
everybody.